in washington president trump is denying
another explosive claim over his efforts
to fight off a series of investigations
this according to the new york times the
president tried to get one of his
supporters
to manage the criminal probe of his
longtime personal lawyer
our paula reed asked the president about
that report yesterday in the oval office
did you ask acting attorney general
matthew would occur to change the
leadership
of the investigation into your former
personal attorney michael cohen
no not at all i don't know who gave you
that just more fake news
a lot of there's a lot of fake there's a
lot of fake news out there no i did
major garrett is at the white house he's
been following the story and has the
latest major good morning
good morning president trump's actions
serious or misconstrued have
periodically raised questions of
obstruction of justice but none of the
investigations
swirling around this administration have
been derailed though they have at times
distracted and dismayed the president
there's now a new episode to consider
according to the new york times
president trump wanted to install a
loyalist to oversee an expanding
investigation by federal prosecutors in
new york
looking into the activities of mr
trump's former lawyer and fixer michael
cohen
the president reportedly asked
then-acting attorney general matt
whitaker
to put u.s attorney for the southern
district of new york and trump ally
jeffrey berman in charge of the cohen
case the acting attorney general
whitaker told the president according
the times
berman had already recused himself from
the investigation and therefore could
not
head it earlier this month whitaker told
congress the president did not ask for
any commitments
involving any investigation raising in
the minds of some house democrats
questions of possible perjury now
questions about obstruction of justice
have been denied by this white house in
every interaction
whether it's been on twitter or actions
the president has been accused of taking
major thank you